Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
If we wish to create an adorable virtual monster
and animate it, we first have to engage in 3D
modeling. Then, if we wish to make it move,
and make this movement believable, we have
to specify where the bones and joints are located
within the model. This process is called rigging.
As you see, it is quite laborious, and requires
expertise in this domain to pull this off.
And now, imagine this process with no 3D
modeling, and no rigging. This is, of course,
impossible…right? Well, now, you know what’s
coming, so hold on to your papers, because
here is a newer technique that indeed performs
the impossible. All we need to do is grab a
pencil and create a rough sketch of our character,
then, it will take a big breath, and inflate it
into a 3D model. This process was nearly 7 times
faster than the classical workflow, but what
matters even more, this new workflow requires
zero expertise in 3D modeling and rigging.
With this technique, absolutely
anybody can become an artist.
So, we noted that these models can also be
animated. Is that so? Yes, that’s right,
we can indeed animate these models by using
these red control points. And even better,
we get to specify where these points go. That’s
a good thing because we can make sure that a
prescribed part can move around, opening up
the possibility of creating and animating
a wide range of characters. And I would say
all this can be done in a matter of minutes,
but even better, sometimes
even within a minute. Whoa.
This new technique does a lot
of legwork that previous methods
were not able to pull off so well. For instance,
it takes a little information about which part
is in front or behind the model. Then, it
stitches all of these strokes together and
inflates our drawing into a 3D model, and it
does this better than previous methods, look.
Well, okay, the new one looks a bit better where
the body parts connect here, and that’s it?
Wait a second…a ha! Somebody
didn’t do their job correctly.
And we went from this work to this, in just
two years. This progress is absolute insanity.
Now let’s have a look at a full workflow from
start to end. First, we draw the strokes,
note that we can specify that one arm and leg is
in front of the body, and the other is behind,
and, bam the 3D model is now done! Wow, that was
quick. And now, add the little red control points
for animation, and let the fun begin! Mister, your
paper has been officially accepted! Move the feet,
pin the hands, rock the body. Wait. Not only
that, but this paper was accepted to the
SIGGRAPH ASIA conference, which is equivalent
to winning an olympic gold medal in computer
graphics research if you will, so add a little
neck movement too. Oh yeah! Now we’re talking!
With this technique, the possibilities really feel
endless. We can animate humanoids, monsters, other
adorable creatures, or can even make scientific
illustrations come to life without any modeling
and rigging expertise. Do you remember this
earlier video where we could paint on a piece of
3D geometry, and transfer its properties onto a 3D
model? This method can be combined with that too.
Yum! And in case you are wondering how quick this
combination is - my goodness. Very, very quick.
Now, this technique is also not perfect,
one of the limitations of this single-view
drawing workflow is that we have only limited
control over the proportions in depth. Texturing
occluded regions is also not that easy. The
authors proposed possible solutions to these
limitations in the paper, so make sure to have a
look in the video description, and it appears to
me that with a little polishing, this may be
ready to go for artistic projects right now.
If you have a closer look, you will also
see that this work also cites the flow paper
from Mihaly Csikszentmihalyi.
Extra style points for that.
And with that said, when can we use this?
And that’s the best part - right now! The authors
really put their papers where their mouth is,
or in other words, the source code for
this project is available, also, there is,
an online demo. Wo-hoo! The link is available
in the video description, make sure to read the
instructions before you start. So there you
go, instant 3D models with animation without
requiring 3D modeling and rigging expertise. What
do you think? Let me know in the comments below!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!